thank you so much what a wonderful
looking cloud crowd you are and I'm very
pleased to have this opportunity to have
a conversation with you about something
a little bit off the beaten track in
this in this conference let me start
with sharing what are my assumptions for
this talk I am figuring that you're
probably experts or very much interested
in data but maybe that you're not very
familiar with learning Sciences that's
my first assumption so if there are some
of you in the audience who are indeed in
the area of Education bear with me as I
take a non-specialists approach to that
I'm also going to frame the stock from
the point of view my point of view as an
educator and a person who is very much
an advocate of open source and whose
research area is computational science
so that informs my point of view and in
the end what I want to do is offer an
invitation for us to work together
between data scientists learning
scientists we're not in the room but
need you and educators who I represent
I'm going to focus as well in higher
education because that's what I'm
familiar most familiar with and but many
of the topics that I'm going to brush on
today are very much very much of
tremendous importance in K to 12
education as well I'm just not familiar
with that context very much
all right so analytics in higher
education traditionally we could say
traditionally although it's recent
universities have been using data quite
well and predictive modeling as well for
informing their administrative processes
so for example they will use analytics
to inform their admissions strategy and
they're very well they're very adept at
this improving enrollment management is
very important colleges and universities
spend millions of dollars in recruitment
so some are using predictive analytics
for example to target their efforts into
specific high
schools they'll have a list of 100 high
school that they recruit from and
they'll have a target of the type of
students they want to recruit and run
some analytics and identify the 10 high
schools where they can get most of those
students and there are success stories
quite amazing success stories of using
analytics in that form student retention
as well is another important application
of predictive analytics at the national
level level retention on average from
freshman to sophomore year is about 75
percent so considering that they've
already spent millions of dollars
recruiting those students it's actually
quite a big loss to have students drop
out so you know student they will
actually the universities will do quite
a bit of effort in retaining the
students building profiles of the
students who are most at risk and trying
to intervene but of course using
analytics to inform admissions strategy
or retention of the university to items
or identifying at-risk students is
nothing to do with learning I believe it
or not these are processes that are
meant to improve the educational system
but admissions rotation on either
graduation are not necessarily the same
as learning yes that's the case there
are different things they're more into
the business process of their education
more and more universities also are
using analytics for informing their
fundraising they will build use
predictive models and build the profile
of the donors who are most likely to
give and they're putting a lot of
efforts into this as well as you can see
a lot of revenue comes to universities
from from from grants sorry from
donations I didn't get a slider that was
more recent but others 2011 30 plus
billion dollars were raised by u.s.
colleges and universities alone
obviously that has nothing to do with
learning but as well it's part of
keeping the educational system going and
a third area where higher education is
influenced by data analytics is rankings
University of ranking
are also related to the framing of
education as an economic activity the
value-for-money idea and increasingly
now that enters into the political arena
where the Obama administration calling
for more accountability from colleges
and proposing even more rankings
centralized rankings managed by the by
the government so data comes into a lot
of areas in higher education but that's
not what we're here to talk about that's
not as a half has nothing to do with
learning we could also say that in the
classroom faculty have been collecting
data on students for a long time of
course you know faculty will take data
on students and how they perform in
assessments they will collect the
dreaded student course assessment and to
have opinions to get the opinions of the
students on how satisfied they are then
they will collect information to satisfy
the requirements of accreditation as
well huge amounts of data collected for
the purposes of accreditation sometimes
also for improving teaching yes in some
but more rarely even more rarely for
research on how students learn but that
is also not learning analytics assigning
grades is not learning analytics because
although grades may be correlated with
learning it's not always the case
think about grade inflation for example
and the purpose of grades is to assist
the students performance after the fact
the purpose is not to improve learning
while it's happening and there's no
action taken beyond perhaps failing the
lower portion learning Allen analytics
proposes that we're going to take some
action to improve the process that we
might be helping students succeed and
collecting grades is just not enough
learning analytics also require some
skill so at the level of a small class
where you're only assigning grades to 30
people or maybe more these days it's
also perhaps not enough so learning is
what is this well it is distinctively a
new trend in education
of course the Google Trends graphic
tells everything about that oh we need
to know and you see learning analytics
jumping in the searches the Google
searches from mid-2011 so yes it's a new
trend in education and it's also a new
research community in fact this research
community has organized itself in the
last few years and there is now a
Society for learning analytics research
acronym solar there's this is an
international network of researchers
that are involved in analytics for
teaching and learning and training
development they held their first
conference in 2011 the international
conference on learning analytics and
knowledge Lak is the acronym and it also
organizes some yearly summer Institute's
and other activities and it has its own
peer-reviewed open access journal which
is self described as the first journal
dedicated to research into the
challenges of collecting analyzing and
reporting data with specific intents of
improving learning ok so what is
learning analytics I've told you what
it's not let's say what it is the fuse
the first often quoted definition of
learning analytics from an edge occurs
report in 2007 it is an activity that
must create actionable intelligence to
improve teaching learning and student
success
you can see how grates not necessarily
fit in there here's a second frequently
cited definition that comes from the
first conference on learning analytics
organized by the Society for learning
analytics research in 2011 it is the
measurement collection analysis and
reporting of data about learners and
their contexts for the purposes of
understanding and optimizing learning ok
let me tell you about a pioneer work in
using you know in learning analytics in
the context of higher education this is
a project from Purdue University called
called horse signals it's a web app and
it's called an early warning system to
trigger individual feedback to students
that may be falling behind in a given
course instructors and advisors can use
this warning system to assist students
and send them personalized emails and
motivate them to get back on track on
track so the key feature here is that
there's I'm going to be there's going to
be some action taken to intervene on
real-time to affect students success
success in the course it is also based
on a predictive model that takes us
input the demographics students grades
attendance their participation in the
learning management system and so on and
it can forecast with fairly good
accuracy that a student may drop out
given the students that of course are at
risk of red light those that are kind of
in the middle yellow light and green
light for those who are not and it comes
from the research of a doctoral student
in Purdue University who examined more
than 70,000 records including 20
variables that he reduced to five
factors seeking to find which
information was a strong indicator of
students dropping out they were the the
research found that there's a regression
model this reduced model accurately
predicted about 60% of students needing
help overall and if you focus only on
freshmen which is the most important
group then this was the Marla was able
to predict about 80% of students needing
help which is fairly good accuracy and
in later years there's this this their
piece D thesis that led to this project
is from 2007 and there was a continued
research on using this web app from 2007
8 9 and this research was published
after all after a while and the Purdue
group claimed that they were able to
increase retention by the use of this
app by 21% now
was seen as that are a really really
important success in the field and
Purdue researchers presented their
results are using course signals at the
2012 the second conference on learning
analytics and knowledge conference in
Vancouver Canada their research
consistent in analyzing about 23,000
students and who had experienced this
system course signals in about a hundred
courses over the span of these three
years and they concluded the students
that participated in course signals that
were supported by this in this feedback
that was triggered by their amber or red
light where we retained at higher rates
than peers who did not have this support
very impressive
they also claimed that students who
experience two or more courses with
signals we're retained at higher rates
than those who had only one course or
zero of course with signals this paper
has been widely cited and was actually
the poster child of the success of
learning analytics there's a little
problem and he's hi any statisticians in
the room any decisions that may have any
suspicions somehow ASM are shaking their
heads it took about two years after it
was published to notice a little bit of
a problem
Purdue claimed that coercing us directly
led to significant statistically
significant they had their p-values and
everything in place gains in retention
but the researchers didn't take into
account the fact that students who take
more courses because they are retained
will be more likely to have more courses
with signals in other in other words yes
if you are retained you're going to take
more courses you see they did not appear
to have controlled for the number of
courses taken well they needed some
statisticians in their team I believe
they had made a very sincere effort to
do research that was unequal at the time
they had they had a
trol group they had all you know it was
these are very respectable researchers
in the community but they have it they
had this little flaw unfortunately and
it led to quite a bit of rattle in the
community only at the end of 2013 and
into 2014 last year the Purdue group
never really responded and they were
calls for them to release their data so
that others could contribute they didn't
do that and so it hasn't really resolved
and you can see well it's a very young
community and I would say and this is
why my invitation is to you that
interdisciplinary teams which are very
hard hard to put together is what what
is needed here in fact there's a very
interesting aspect of this story in 2013
and late 2013 alfred essa who is a
researcher added a VP of research in
mcgraw-hill analytics published a blog
post that was titled can we improve
retention by giving students chocolate
so he coded up a simulation where
students were randomly given chocolates
on each course that they took he got
similar results to the results that were
presented in this singles paper so in
other words there's a strong correlation
between the number of chocolates the
students got and their retention but of
course this doesn't mean that chocolate
makes you study it only means that more
courses you take more chances to be
retained this simple effect of reverse
correlation okay so the Alfred SR
concluded that the direct costs ality
attributed to course analysis spurious
in fact causation is the reverse or was
what it was claimed and students who
take course signals were just more
likely to graduate the non-core signal
students but students who take her
signals are not more likely to graduate
than those who don't take did don't
participate in the program they're just
more likely to take more courses
let me move on to another very important
player in this whole environment which
is the dreaded despised LMS the LMS is
the learning management system and this
is a huge powerhouse in education it's
the centerpiece of educational
technology and I would say has 95 I
don't know what somewhere between 90 and
100 just shy of 100 penetration in the
higher education world's billion-dollar
industry
LMS of course the LMS vendors having
crew introduced their dashboards their
dazzling dashboards sar dashboards here
we are with an image search for the term
lms dashboards not just a sports LMS
dashboards here we are but what do they
measure what do they measure the measure
learning they measure attending did the
students log in did they turn in their
assignments here is an example this was
touted as the first you know retention
center for for students learning
management retention forgive my slightly
cynical tone of voice they measure who's
logging in
okay maybe who's logging in has some
correlation to those students are will
be more successful so instructors see of
course who's how long since the students
have been logged in and their flag with
a red light if the student has to logged
in for five consecutive days whether
they're engaged
have they been participating in the
discussion forums maybe they have a
participation of 20% or less than the
average red light
who's greater suffering with which
students are curling trending at 25%
below the average red light who has
missed deadlines instructors might know
this like anecdotally because they see
but they've moved they have a big class
maybe they want to get
is automated alright real-time view of
all students that have missed a deadline
in other words it's really a basic user
activity report one credit called it
trivial descriptive statistics a simple
set of reports overlaid with database
queries yet it was the first so-called
retention dashboard of a learning
management system the leader in the
field and in the peon in 2013 so not so
long ago this is one example of what a
product that's called now an early
warning system in fact produced course
signals was also an early warning system
detects when students are at risk of
dropping out it uses data from the
digital footprint of students in the
online learning environments and it
tries to combine all those variables of
course logins forum posts of the grade
book and so on into some indication of
students that are at risk but it knows
nothing about the content of the course
and certainly knows nothing about the
learning that is happening there
certainly there's some benefits of
course the group at Purdue reported that
this the signals project did indeed for
example develop students more
metacognitive skills so for the students
themselves to know when there might be
an at-risk or to enhance theirs
help-seeking behavior so in a way you
know there are so of course there are
some benefits but they're often inflated
the data sources for these types of
things are the learning management
systems of course but in really any
interaction between the student and the
institution through a digital platform
can inform these types of systems for
example the use of university services
like going to the library or student
advising these can be tracked with card
swipes and all of this can be fed into
the student information system and can
be used to detect students that may be
at risk and this of course is the
promise
serve this type of product enter Big
Data tracking every click every quiz
every quiz question the student gets
wrong how long they take in each lesson
every granular piece of content that
they touch the idea of so called
adaptive learning comes from the concept
of running some machine learning
algorithms in searching in search of
patterns to adapt the learning sequence
to each student according to patterns
that have been seen to be related to
success the poster child of adaptive
learning is this company called Newton
they sign huge deals with publishing
houses like Pearson and Arizona State
University and 2012 they raised 50
million dollars they were tracing
everything that the student did in their
system even if students mouse was waving
around between question a and questions
C for a while they tracked that too
still there's little evidence that this
technology really improves or effects in
any way in learning which is much more
complex if you think about it then
choosing a movie at night or getting a
book recommendation it really is a lot
more than that and the lack of any
peer-reviewed publications supporting
the claim that that adaptive learning
really is going to change education plus
the proprietary nature of the algorithms
quickly attracted a lot of criticism
here's a quote from this MIT review
report there's little evidence to say
whether newton's technology actually
teaches better by the way when it says
for the non-native speakers when it says
little evidence it means no evidence
Microsoft by the way signed an agreement
with mutant in 2012 Microsoft has
invested a huge amount of money in
educating their education division and
they have cultivated a wide partner
network of publishers and other partners
this partnership with mutant promised to
put the adaptive engine to the service
of this network I'm not quite sure why I
came out of it I'm trying to if I could
hear from anybody here that knows
anything I'd be really interested I
searched and searched I couldn't find
anything all of these systems that have
been describing to you rely on the idea
that students remain in one walled
garden the learning platform the online
learning platform this is sometimes
called the learning in a box model of
Education in fact most analytics and
education is based exclusively on logs
in the learning management system but we
both we all know that both students and
faculty use a plethora of apps and web
services and move around all over the
place and this idea that you're going to
do everything through the one login only
learning management system it's not it's
not adequate it does not that's not
really how people learn but this is what
is the promise of these products and the
other assumption 0 of this type of
activity is that well
more data more learning that's the first
assumption that probably needs to be
tested the most basic assumption of this
it takes solutions called adaptive
learning it reminds me of what has now
come to be known as technological
solution ISM the idea this tendency to
give very simple answers before the
question I think fully asked for example
education is failing students adaptive
learning will fix it
this is a classic example of techno
solution ISM it has these features its
context-free it knows nothing about
history it ignores completely the
history of the whole field and it has
poor or non-existent theory and touts
very ambitious goals if anything that
you hear has these things just classify
the stigma solution ISM and apply your
suspicious antennas this explains the
dazzling dashboards by the way and this
is a very nice quote that I want to
share with you from Justin Wright our
well-known researcher in the Harvard X
corporation it's a corporation even
though it's a non-profit big data sets
do not by virtue of their size
inherently possess answers to
interesting questions we have terabytes
of data about what students clicked and
very little understanding of what
changed in their heads
this hasn't - lling dashboards again
haha dazzling dashboards I love this
quote by Edward - tuftan a vast
wasteland of pretentious banality isn't
that lovely
and it was text perfectly timed for my
talk May 2015 I was so lucky to run into
that right yes please please take a
picture of that save it save it a vast
wasteland of pretentious banality I just
wanted to say that again adaptive
learning is here's another one adaptive
learning is like an iPod with infinite
capacity and infinite capability to play
this any song ever recorded as long as
it was written by Neil Diamond or is
this a fabulous blog post about this if
all you've ever heard in your life were
songs by Neil Diamond probably you think
this is a wonderful product right
so it is with these futurists they
probably have never seen a class where
math is anything but a teaching
lecturing in front of the board
describing a procedure and students
replicating that procedure 20 times on a
piece of paper that entire universe fits
within a computer adaptive model but is
that how learning happens in every
classroom is that well how learning
should happen in any classroom so I
guess if we want to really contribute to
learning analytics the first question we
should be asking is what is learning
what really is knowledge does learning
happen here in this environment is this
just it or as pigley would say is that
all there is only the jazz fans know my
joke okay you can look it up in YouTube
afterwards it's fantastic a traditional
view of knowledge might associate it
with facts and sets of propositions that
you remember that you memorize but this
is a very limited view of knowledge very
utilitarian view and we know that in
reality remembering facts is not useful
think about how you work think about how
scientists work I mean if you learn
something you're going to call your
friend you're going to go online search
in google make some connections
partially get the idea of what's
happening then start completing a
network of small contributions to
something that appears as if a image and
an image is coming into focus slowly at
a distance this is this is how it really
happens so this linear collection of
fact after fact that you remember modern
the modern views of knowledge are much
richer than that we say that knowledge
is distributed and if you're a coder you
know what I'm talking about you can't
hardly complete a project without Google
or your friends
today we say we talk about knowledge as
something that's connective connective
knowledge knowledge that is created and
shared by an interconnected community of
individuals that's why this that we have
a community that actually is a strong
community is so powerful so in this view
with the learning really the learner
really needs to participate in this
community engage in the community this
is why open education is so important it
has a pedagogical purpose open education
involving sharing not just access to
materials but sharing creating your own
artifacts and sharing those artifacts
within your network this is our modern
understanding of how knowledge is
created through this distributed
interconnect connected network between
students and faculties and as an aside
this is by the way why in 2001 so 14
years ago MIT had no problems deciding
to make all of their contents available
for free in what now has become this
wave of open courseware because they
know that their knowledge is not on just
the lessons the lesson plans or the PDF
of the assignments the collective
knowledge on the power of MIT is in the
students and faculty they're in the
campus interacting together who cares if
I put my PDFs online that's not an MIT
education sure have it for free
knowledge is distributed so this is what
I strongly believe is the pedagogical
purpose of open sharing and this is the
tenets of the where people call in
learning scientists and learning science
connectivism involves after
constructivism the theory of knowledge
Jay and so on connectivism is the thesis
that knowledge is distributed across a
network of connections and therefore
learning consists of the ability to
construct and traverse those networks so
learning is deeply social and we heard
that yesterday as well
steep the social then learning analytics
must include as well social network
analysis the use of graph techniques to
assess the strength of interpersonal
relationships there's also very
interesting work being done in discourse
analysis using natural language
processing to for example analyze forum
posts and detect sense making processes
where the quality of the debates the
Eureka moments on the basis of the
language that is being used by the
students as you can see a much richer
environment that can be absorbed by the
dazzling dashboard of the LMS enter the
MOOCs the M word as Parker said
yesterday into all this kerfuffle one of
the top MOOC providers EDX which are a
little bit more familiar with released
its analytics product in November last
year with great from far that's only
eight months ago and it looks like this
it tracks a romance so how many people
have enrolled to you to this open course
of course I'm tracking enrollments does
have some use you know it might be
useful to evaluate your marketing
campaigns strategies that enough has
nothing to do with learning obviously it
tracks demographics well some anymore
demographics information may be useful
ma'am yeah we worry about the fact that
most MOOC takers are male you know we
would want to have more diverse
participation in these types of open
education activities yes but it has
nothing to do with learning again the
dashboard of course gives you very
pretty plot of age educational level and
and so on gender demographics and it has
its value here's a typical education
metric
very typical that's well similarly
geographic information might be useful
but not so much and in the next level we
have engagement data all the engagement
ah fixation well it could be useful to
assess certain elements maybe some
course design aspects this is nothing
about learning but yes we have to take
care of those things the user experience
of course
and this is a type of data that has been
used to for example give instructors
guidelines as to the ideal length of
their videos should be six minutes
because students drop out after that
it's just the clickstream says it so
your video
everybody's video should be six minutes
No
Oh mathematics history at all different
art photography six minutes the insights
dashboard seems to have built in weekly
binning as well it doesn't allow you to
change that so the frequency of data
displays weekly you can see which
students were active in a given week and
so on who watch the video the desk
doesn't seem to be any way to explore a
more granular data but of course it is
somewhere they are deep in the logs and
finally we have aggregated data on the
grade the grades the graded content and
yes this can allow us to instruct us to
detect faulty content maybe some problem
is badly designed
and yes it's useful so overall this is
it overall a step backwards I would say
putting analytics into the service of
user experience rather than education
perhaps influenced by the teams that
develop this that are probably a lot of
web dev people they know about web
analytics and this is this is what they
know and I don't know maybe they didn't
interact with learning scientists and
the educators to ask them what
information they might find useful now
why is this a problem with so many
education so many in education now
looking to MOOCs as some sort of
inspiration to change her overall
educational system it's a problem that
we take a step backwards in something
like how we use analytics to inform the
educational actions that we take why
here's a quote that sums it up
this is Simon Buckingham Shum who was
previously at the UK's Open University a
very well-known researcher in learning
and he says our learning is our pedagogy
what does that mean this is shorthand
for saying that analytics have implied
in them particular approaches to
learning and assessment and there are
assumptions there's a worldview if you
will in the data that was collected and
the way that it was displayed so of all
we're measuring is a clique stream in
the mint learning management system then
perhaps we'll be optimizing for the
wrong thing maybe education will move
closer to entertainment without any
concern for authentic learning so what
we measure shapes our reality behind
every dazzling dashboard behind every
data set collected there are assumptions
that need to be tested and this is the
difference according to John Boehner's
quoted here at Pearson between a data
technician and a data scientist the data
scientist knows that there are
assumptions behind every data set and
every way that it's been analyzed the
first assumption that is made of course
is what data to collect and we know this
also from the field of economy the
economists have long for law for a long
time said that accounting tools are not
neutral so they don't simply measure
economic activity they shape it and in
the same way what we measure in learning
will shape our educational system who is
deciding what data to collect and how
reported do the analytics really reflect
what we care about as educators that's
what we should be asking in other words
data is not neutral and perhaps that
applies to more than education other
activities where your may be involved
judgments and decisions were made about
what to collect analytics can create or
even magnify contexts or differences or
inequalities what about when analytics
starts being used to judge you
as a learner as an educator as a school
in the UK for example analytics reports
are used to evaluate teachers to
evaluate their performance and if their
graphs are not right they lose their job
they can lose their job so data is
definitely not neutral we enter into a
political quagmire there of course that
politics starts but the politics starts
to being a factor in this whole thing
what about algorithms there's a lot of
assumptions as well in the algorithms
and this is why I strongly believe that
in this area of Education it is
absolutely crucial that the whole
pipeline of analytics be open source
because the algorithms hold so many
assumptions about thresholds samples how
the new how the numerix were calculated
it was said yesterday
in the in the testing talk as well what
values were used we use in each one of
these variables affects the outcome so
we need algorithmic transparency the
whole way through especially in
something like it's education and
especially if some people's jobs are
also going to be dictated by what
numbers come out of that dashboard but
the bottom line is that EdTech is big
business I bet some of you were thinking
about some business ideas during this
talk in 2014 venture capital funds
private equity investors and
transnational corporations poured over
3.5 billion dollars into education
technology in the US alone it's big
business so transparency in algorithms
and sharing an open sharing of data sets
it's quite an issue of course in this
context but buzzwords and hype aside
learning analytics has to have grounding
in learning Sciences in addition to
using sound statistical techniques
remember the course signals small pick
up it has to pay attention to historical
backgrounds as well often ignored
completely by MOOCs by the whole shebang
things like the cognitive models
cognitive tutors Carnegie Mellon's
history in that in that area are using
artificial intelligence for education
that camp goes back to 1970
there's loads of publications about that
all of these guys 2011 forwards seem to
not all of them of course some
researchers are quite serious about it
but many the groups behind some of these
projects ignore all of that history the
first popular attempt to actually use a
mechanical device to teach students goes
to 1926 believe it or not 1926 so
basically a mechanical multiple-choice
machine we also have to pay attention to
the fact that learning is deeply social
as Paco said yesterday so I want to
suggest that in this arena its most
important to form interdisciplinary
teams we know this is very hard but
learning scientists and educators need
data scientists and the only way for
this to actually be fruitful and
revolutionised education is for all of
us to work together and this is I think
one of the most important aspects the
social aspect of need of learning what
peak pack was an eight-pack renascence
said last night he said it's not so much
about how an individual learns rather
our focus should be should include the
social context I quickly wrote down a
quote yesterday and current adaptive
learning system so once I described
earlier really focus on the idea of the
individual with a device that's it
that's where learning happens a fallacy
of course an individual in front of a
machine well learning in a box that's
not real
usually delivered sequential contact
perhaps with different learning paths
word but it's just very granular
elements of content that you have to
navigate and that's it but that's not
how people learn learning is deeply
social students and faculty use a wide
array of web services many of them
reflecting their social activities
either you should share YouTube videos
perhaps write on a blog they have shared
Google Documents and so on
so should we track everything
to actually produce some learning
analytics that can help in education
well this starts getting a little bit
creepy very fast this is a small
experiment in Dartmouth College where
they collect the data using an Android
app that tracked all of their physical
activities of the students where they
spend their time GPS of course they were
they were able to predict pretty well
they're cheap their GPA at the end of
the term it's very recent work and is
very small-scale but they're planning on
taking this to the largest scale and
they're already talking about the Fitbit
of learning you like that huh but what
about privacy who has going to is going
to hold that in the UK with the European
laws on privacy are much more strong a
foundation with very broad membership in
universities published like just last
month this code of practice for learning
analytics addressing particularly the
rights of students to consent I mean let
alone they're probably not even informed
that they're being tracked in these
other systems but consent privacy
validity of the information do they have
access to their own information these
are very very important topics and of
course if they're detect any errors will
they be able to do it will there be due
process for they to change that if they
move to another university they own
their own data can they bring their data
to the other university it's very
complicated so again I guess this circle
that I was drawing is even too
simplistic because in addition to data
scientists learning scientists and
educators we need social scientists and
maybe privacy experts and legal experts
so as you can see it's a very very
complicated inter relation of concerns
which is the idea that I wanted to bring
up to to your conscience today it
requires really a comprehensive set of
different skills and a fully
interdisciplinary Enterprise in any case
this very attractive idea of using
analytics to personalize education and
the dollar signs in the eyes of the
etiquette
preneur flash when they think about
adaptive learning this has a long way to
go a long way to go but maybe the next
time you hear machine learning you might
think that we have two different
possible meanings to machine learning
one is the algorithms that you know and
love at the heart of the PI data
community and the other one is this idea
of trying to mechanize the process of
education often reducing it without
understanding it this is actually a
postcard from nine for $18.99
a vision of the year 2000 of what
education would look like and I will
leave you with this image
and I've been told they're the best
thing you can do for your audiences to
finish early so I think I have a few
minutes for questions no that's great we
certainly do have a few minutes for
questions the main sessions are starting
at 10 o'clock so if you feel the need to
leave for a short break before that
otherwise we could definitely be running
the microphones around for some
questions right now seems like one of
the biggest problems is being able to
quantify learning you listed a bunch of
things that weren't worth optimizing
grades enrollment retention to maximize
learning so what is the current view of
quantifying learning because once you
get that nailed down it seems like all
of the work will come easily after that
so what is the current view I don't
think that anybody has the answer to
that
in fact there's always contrary
contrarians to every movement to to
quantify or to assess learning even when
people talk about things like writing
learning objectives for every course
there's a another group of people that
say well you know it's not about the
outcome education needs to be purpose
driven not outcome driven the experience
is what really counts the and how would
you possibly measure that it's it's the
learning they learn each learner could
be different and experience something
different and that could be equally
valuable so it's extremely complex
that's why I said it's not like
recommending a movie and this is the why
this is a really interesting research
topic and a very important one I don't
think anyone knows the answer to your
question so I'm curious about your
opinion on purely outcomes based
analytics and specifically I'm thinking
of an article that I was reading about a
Florida University that is having its
state funding based on the outcomes of
its students landing jobs those jobs
paying what was considered appropriate
for the forecasting and for
time yeah well there are dangers in in
any attempt to the additional dangers
that come in there of course are the
politics every time you try to use
assessment to determine how much money
and institution is going together who
keeps their job all sorts of diabolic
tensions come in and it is very
difficult to resist those forces of
accountability which have a reasonable
and valid route which is to provide
students with a real opportunity in life
and not just a ball and chain of debt
it's a real important concern but sadly
the the people who are usually making
those decisions about how to enforce
this accountability and what to measure
have very narrow views about well how
education should function should we even
measure if students are happy in this
whole process is it even matter if
they're if you know their emotional
state for example because if you put
everybody through them them sort of
churning them through a machine in maybe
they're going to be very useful for
society until they commit suicide you
know so if I I am naturally suspicious
and resistance to those forces but I
don't know what the answer is to stop
them because they have a valid route
how about detecting Eureka moments can
you point toward examples of not
necessarily measuring this is data a bit
the practice as a teacher I well in
online platforms there are very very
interesting results in using natural
language processing in detecting certain
patterns of conversation that flagged
these types of these types of moments I
think this is very interesting I I am
very curious about that in the were you
asking about the real face-to-face
environment of Education I mean I think
it's a different take on on assessing
the dialogue between the the learners
and whoever is that they're guiding the
content there are some efforts to codify
language patterns between in regards to
the action that's being taken in regards
there's some really interesting efforts
to construct some schemas of
interactions in this course that I'm not
entirely familiar with but I think it's
very interesting I know of it Carnegie
Mellon there's a group there studying
that I think that's going to be very
important as we move more and more of
our interactions online I so um so
there's obviously a lot of different
types of learners and different types of
educators is there any way that learning
analytics can be used to sort of match
up an educator and a learner to know if
you would get the most out of a
particular course I'm not sure that it
is implicit in your question but
nevertheless I want to address
immediately a misconception that exists
very widely in our society of a very
attractive concept that has spread like
wildfire that is bunk and that is
learning styles people use this
terminology of learning styles oh I'm an
visual learner oh I'm a motor or
whatever learning there's a
classification and it appeared in the
literature spread everywhere because
it's a very attractive idea but if
there's no evidence
that this is real everybody has a
spectrum of abilities there aren't
really learning styles but of course we
can learn with all of our senses and a
teacher will be most effective if they
use all of the available channels of
communication to reinforce what they
want to teach but that that that
spectrum needs to be simply navigated
where the idea of diversity in mind like
we do everything else I had the same
question thanks learning styles don't be
don't be fooled it's it's a it's made up
hi first I really enjoyed your talk I
thought it was awesome and very
courageous I have the experiencing and
you know undergrad and grad school that
as my professors became more
quantitative they're grading styles
became less quantitative and so I
actually felt like you know maybe it was
that they appreciated you know the
inherent kind of subjectivity in their
own like analysis of or like trying to
measure learning and so that they were
actually kind of backing off of
quantitative methods so I was wondering
is the answer maybe you know do we need
to be educating decision makers who
believe that you know we should measure
and optimize everything including humans
you know in statistics is that the
answer maybe is to actually like you
know educate the decision makers ideally
we would increase the level of
statistical literacy across all
decision-makers especially in education
a lot of times the efforts to measure
and assess
are are based on this this are based on
a lack of trust and this is that they
are the key of the whole dynamic is to
increase trust in each other so that the
assessment can be relaxed one of the
reasons perhaps you experience that is
that as you mature it as a student your
professors trusted you more and there's
no need to you know make sure every
every everything you do and and this is
a sad situation in of course in the
tension between administrators
policymakers and educators also affected
there's a lot of politics in this
affected by the fact that in education
and increasingly we have low paid
professorial in natural positions and so
they have to make a living and obviously
the quality is going to decrease and so
now they want to assess more because the
quality is being affected but it's all a
very systemic situation but I recommend
as a side note I recommend a video and
YouTube by Eric Mazur and Harvard titled
assessment the silent killer of
education over here so I've this is
regarding secondary education I'm I
witnessed this once removed my wife as a
teacher I would say a master teacher of
mathematics and that whole class of
teachers is engaged it seems to me and a
power struggle down with an
administrative class which is tripled in
the last 20 years so those
administrators love this approach of
learning in the box and the master
teachers who are the people all the
students remember that made their
education are profoundly skeptical of
these approaches but what can be done
the administrators have a lot of power
right now and they there's so many of
them they're looking for things to do so
they're making up new tasks for the
teachers are taking them out of what
they really want to do in the classroom
so how do we win this struggle it is a
struggle
the typical struggle of
you know it's a power struggle right I
think the usual way we do things in
democracy is we organize at the
grassroots we stay on message and we
have a unified front we use facts and
theory and our communication skills to
reach out to the other communities in
language they can understand this is my
effort coming here and giving you this
dog even though it's a little bit
off-topic thank you very much I don't
want to keep you any longer and thank
you for your interest with the questions
do you want to have a last question
offline yeah so I'll just ask it I'm
data scientist and I love data but I'm
also very much troubled by the hyper
quantification of Education and in
learning because I think there's a major
sort of cognitive disconnect between the
idea of using data to sort of improve
learning but also this notion of having
a solid liberal arts education and what
it means to become a citizen and and be
a fully human participant in the world
with other people as a social sort of
social construct so how do we how do we
both how do we achieve both outcomes you
know the federal government cares a lot
about people getting jobs and not being
mired in ball-and-chain of debt and
that's really great but how do we also
sort of achieve this other
unquantifiable goal of growing a
citizenship with thinkers and people who
care deeply about those who live in
society I'm troubled by both of those
things and how as a data scientist can
can we help the educators and learning
scientists to sort of protect the data
in such a way that it doesn't fall into
the hands of politicians and other folks
who don't care about that sort of
citizenship part
if I knew the answer to that obviously
and well I think the key one of the keys
in something like that is to be able to
talk beyond your peers to be able to
reach out to others in other disciplines
and find a common common mission and
seek those I mean I I hate to use the
bathroom of the buzzword of
interdisciplinary teams but this is
really this is really hard to accomplish
and of course that Berkeley data science
the Institute is making this effort of
putting social scientists and data
science working together and their
Washington Institute we heard yesterday
as well is understanding that really
teams need to be interdisciplinary
there's no such thing as data science
without other scientists right we have
to understand that that we we need to
work across our comfort zone of people
who talk our own language and that's the
hardest thing to do everything lies at
the edge of the everything important is
going to lie at the edge of your
discipline and another discipline you
have to be willing to go there to those
unexplored lands and and talk to people
who are not like you yes yes yeah I'm
disappointed that so many people have
left and didn't get to hear that because
that is such an important thing that we
always need to be aware of let's thank
the rena one more time yeah thank you so
much